[Musique]
l'Institut national des sciences et
industries du vivant et de
l'environnement une école d'ingénieurs
spécialisée dans les thématiques très
actuelles que sont le climat
l'environnement l'alimentation durable
les biotechnologies la chimie les
matériaux
l'innovation et l'entrepreneuriat sont
deux grands sujets pour AgroParisTech
étant donné les sujets sur lesquels nous
sommes positionnés et cet accompagnement
prend la forme de deux principaux
dispositifs un premier qui est des jurys
successifs à destination de nos
étudiants de nos diplômés et
éventuellement des enseignants
chercheurs de l'École donc c'est jury
permettent à la fois de faire grandir
les projets et aussi de les soutenir
financièrement à travers deux
partenaires la Fondation AgroParisTech
et agroparita innovation le deuxième
dispositif dédié à l'innovation
AgroParisTech et le réseau des innabs
qui sont des incubateurs scientifiques
et techniques qui nous permettent
d'aider nos porteurs de projets à
développer des preuves de concept et
donc à se lancer dans l'aventure
entrepreneuriale ces incubateurs sont
thématiques et sont répartis sur les
différents sites d'AgroParisTech le Food
inLab sur le campus de Palaiseau adresse
les problématiques liées à
l'alimentation durable les nouvelles
sources de protéines le packaging donc
les nouveaux emballages les nouveaux
aliments la nutrition le farming Lab est
situé sur la ferme expérimentale
d'AgroParisTech à grignons et nous
permet d'étudier le lien entre
l'agriculture et les nouvelles
technologies numériques l'intelligence
artificielle et la
le biotechnab sur notre campus de Reims
permet d'utiliser les sciences du vivant
pour la production de molécules
d'intérêt pour les secteurs cosmétiques
pharmaceutiques et agroalimentaires et
le forestinglab dédié au sens forestière
sur notre campus de Nancy nous permet
d'étudier et d'accompagner les projets
en lien avec la gestion forestière de
pilotage par satellite et la question
des crédits carbone
[Musique]
agro ParisTech accompagne aujourd'hui
entre 70 et 80 projets de création
d'entreprise nous avons une moyenne de
15 créations d'entreprises par an et
nous voyons que c'est en progression
donc c'est un élément encourageant et ce
sont des projets qui aujourd'hui
marchent bien fonctionnent survivre
après trois ou cinq ans et ce sont aussi
des projets et des entreprises qui
lèvent des fonds puisque en 2022
l'ensemble des projets entrepreneuriaux
d'AgroParisTech on le met un peu plus de
60 millions d'euros
sur le plateau de Saclay et pour nous
une vraie opportunité en matière
d'entrepreneuriat d'innovation dans le
sens où elle nous permet de faire plus
de liens entre la recherche et nos
étudiants porteurs de projets et
également de nous connecter à cette
écosystème de Paris Saclay et à des
partenaires très importants pour nous
notamment comme centrale Supélec nous
avons en effet un programme
d'accompagnement d'accélération commun
twenty first qui nous permet
d'accompagner conjointement des projets
issus des deux établissements
[Musique]